what's happening right now is that there
is this feeling amongst the Democrat
Party like he got us through the
midterms somehow like he's still alive
whatever but can he run again right
because we this is all gearing up to the
2024 situation and Corrine jump here was
asked about that because Democrats are
finally starting to question I would say
his mental Acumen is physical health and
just like should they just get rid of
him at this point he served the purpose
he he did what the system needed him to
do and now the system can get rid of his
old bones
majority of Democrats don't want the
president uh to seek re-election they uh
they look for new generation concerns
about his age without getting into
whether or not the president will will
announce does the president believe that
he has to address those concerns from
his own constituents so um as you've
just laid out I'm going to be very
careful covered by the Hatch Act don't
want to get into uh the specifics of
what 2024 is going to look like or any
underlying components of that the
president has been very clear he intends
to run and you know I think the way that
we should look at this is what we saw
from the midterms
just so many words it's just word after
word but they say absolutely nothing but
a girl like her a gal like her she's got
to go down with the ship gay Pete's got
to go down and ship they're all in on
the nonsense so they all have to be in
on the nonsense until the pressure
becomes so much to bear that they can
get off and they will they will gladly
gladly bury Joe Biden in the name of
continuing their careers that is the
beauty of this thing like this does not
end well
[Music]
thank you